il ya 50 ans la guerre de corée faisait
plus d'un million de morts au final un
pays séparé en deux pour mieux
comprendre l'enjeu de ce premier sommet
retour sur une page d'histoire avec
régis nussbaum
c'est le premier conflit brûlant de la
guerre froide nous sommes en 1950 la
guerre de corée vient d'éclater
le nord communiste soutenu par l'union
soviétique de staline et la chine de mao
envahi le sud de la péninsule
l'invasion sera repoussée par les
américains sous le drapeau des nations
unies la guerre dure trois ans et ses
deux millions et demi de morts
1953 l'armistice est signé
désormais le 38e parallèle divise la
corée en deux par une ligne
infranchissable au sud les présidents se
succèdent dans un régime autoritaire
le pays vit sous la protection des
soldats américains
il va connaître de graves crises comme
la révolte des étudiants en 1981 la
marche sera longue avant de parvenir à
la démocratie à la fin des années 90
mais dans le même temps la corée du sud
est devenue une puissance économique et
industriel de premier plan en asie au
nord en revanche rien n'a changé en un
demi siècle de dictature du parti unique
pyongyang est devenu l'un des régimes
les plus stalinien et fermés au monde
un seul exemple les boutons des postes
de radio sont bloqués sur la radio
nationale vous pouvez pas essayer
d'avoir un autre poste et même à post
chinois j'ai vu dire post communiste
chinois parade militaire et culte
extravagant de la personnalité autour de
kim il sung le fondateur avant que kim
jong-il et son fils ne lui succède
car la corée du nord a inventé la
première dynastie communiste
mais avec la chute du communisme
pyongyang a perdu ses derniers appui et
le régime est contraint à rencontrer
pour la première fois les frères ennemis
du sud
fait que la corée du nord est acceptée
ce sommet indique que la situation est
particulièrement mauvaise et que la
corée du nord acceptent de de courir un
certain danger en se mettant à la table
des négociations
la situation alimentaire est extrêmement
mauvaise car si la corée du nord s'est
lancée dans un programme nucléaire et le
connaît parallèlement une terrible
famine
près de deux millions de personnes
seraient déjà mortes de faim
principalement des enfants
demain la riche et prospects corée du
sud pourrait donc apporter son aide à
son voisin du nord en échange d'une
réunification des familles séparées
depuis plus d'un demi siècle